we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
very practical question about the 2020
election take a listen to this hey david
this a quarter from southern california
i have a question about the online site
i side with calm i'm sure you've heard
it I put the quiz reason to show a
couple co-workers mine to see where they
would possibly align politically but I'm
noticing i side with doesn't necessarily
have concrete facts i notice that i
lined up more tulsi gabbard but based on
what you explained about her on your
video and the research i doing the line
from voting record it seems like eating
realistic a little line up alongside
with it rather more long lines of energy
in anyway i guess my question is what do
you think about service.com as a
reliable voting measurement thank you
yeah so listen it might have been hard
to understand what the caller was saying
he's talking about i side with which is
a website that asks you questions about
your political views and then it tells
you which twenty twenty candidates you
were most aligned with politically there
is something wrong with the website i
did this the other day during a live
stream and one of the top people that
lined me up with was kirsten gillibrand
and the reason it said i was lined up
with kirsten gillibrand was her views on
socialism match mine that we are both
sort of socialists and of course she's
not a socialist and i'm not a socialist
so i do think that there is something
weird going on with I side with and I
would caution people about reading too
directly into the results that it comes
up with glad that someone called in and
brought this up ok we've got a great
bonus show for you today we will talk
about the non future of Amazon's
headquarters in New York City we will
talk about a Washington State bill to
Van ban philosophical vaccine exemptions
and lastly we will talk about a deal
that has been reached by a former NFL
player Colin Kaepernick with the NFL
regarding collusion allegations all of
those stories and more on the bonus show
become a member to get access to the
bonus show look
forward to speaking to you then